Мінський процес, "нормандський формат",
вирішення конфлікту на Донбасі лише мирним шляхом,
санкції проти Росії та невизнання анексії Криму -
складові політики щодо України,
яку Меркель проводить уже більше трьох років.
До того Україна лише зрідка з’являлася на порядку денному канцлерки -
в контексті газових воєн між Києвом та Москвою,
критики ув’язнення Юлії Тимошенко та готовності пролікувати
її в Німеччині, а також ініціативи Східного партнерства ЄС.
За 12 років її канцлерства в Україні змінилися три президенти
- не кажучи вже про прем’єр-міністрів.
За увесь цей час вона лише один раз відвідала Україну -
23 серпня 2014 року.
І хоча зустріч з українськими високопосадовцями
тривала лише кілька годин, цей візит був дуже
символічним проявом підтримки України.
По-перше, це відбулося на тлі запеклих боїв на Донбасі.
По-друге - напередодні Дня незалежності України.
Тим часом українські урядовці були частими гостями в Берліні.
Петро Порошенко за три роки свого президентства
11 разів відвідав Берлін - стільки,
скільки всі його попередники разом узяті.
Не кажучи вже про численні телефонні розмови або
зустрічі на полях інших міжнародних майданчиків.
Меркель взяла на себе чи не провідну роль у
намаганнях знайти дипломатичне рішення конфлікту на Донбасі.
Нормандський формат, Мінськ-1, а згодом і Мінськ-2,
про який домовлялися рекордні 16 годин,
великою мірою - її заслуга.
Також Меркель докладала зусиль, аби переконати партнерів по ЄС
зайняти одностайну позицію в питанні санкцій проти Росії.
Уряд Меркель на рівні різних міністерств надає Україні допомогу:
з децентралізації, відбудови Донбасу, підтримки
внутрішніх переселенців, лікування
поранених військовослужбовців тощо.
Разом з тим позиція Анґели Меркель щодо
перспективи членства України у ЄС відома давно:
на її думку, це питання зараз не на часі.
Як і питання членства в НАТО.
Тим не менше Меркель висловлюється за інтенсивнішу співпрацю
між Україною та альянсом, а також активнішу
євроінтеграцію України в межах угоди про асоціацію.
Півроку тому партія Меркель - нехай і зі значними втратами -
знову перемогла на виборах.
Після найдовших і навйважчих в історії ФРН
коаліційних переговорів нарешті створено
нову урядову коаліцію.
І це знову так звана "велика" коаліція ХДС/ХСС із соціал-демократами.
І хоча міністр закордонних справ зміниться -
замість Зіґмара Ґабріеля ним стане теж, соціал-демократ,
колишній міністр юстиції Гайко Маас -
політика Берліна щодо Києва, судячи з коаліційної угоди,
залишатиметься незмінною.
У програмному документі нового уряду ФРН
Україні присвячено окремий розділ.
Там зазначено, що новий німецький уряд буде підтримувати
відновлення територіальної цілісності та суверенітету України.
Для виконання мінських угод пропонується
скерувати на Донбас оонівську місію "блакитних шоломів".
Санкції ж проти Росії можуть бути скасовані лише за
умови виконання мінських домовленостей.
У коаліційній угоді також звертається увага на те, що
українська влада має ефективніше впроваджувати реформи,
особливо у сфері боротьби з корупцією.